[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine richtig adventliche
torte und zwar mache ich einen
käsekuchen mit einer frucht schicht und
bc obendrauf richtig lecker und fruchtig
und das ganze könnt ihr wirklich super
vorbereitet für euren adventssonntag
oder auch einfach mal so wenn ihr lust
auf eine winterliche dort habt ich werde
jetzt zuerst einmal einen weg zu
bereiten
und hier habe ich jetzt einen schoko
möge teig und sag ich mal die zutaten
für den mürbeteig verwende ich 250 gramm
mehl 50 gramm kakaopulver 100 gramm
zucker eine prise salz 200 gramm kalte
butter 1 eigelb und ein bisschen
tonkabohne für den möbel zeigt nämlich
jetzt zuerst die kalte butter
die habe ich bereits in stückchen
geschnitten die kommt in eine
rührschüssel da kommt der zucker dazu
und das salz jetzt kann ich die drei
zutaten schon mal verbinden
jetzt kommt hier noch das eigelb das tun
wird eingerührt und zum schluss würde
ich hier noch das mehl und das
kakaopulver dazu und geht noch ein
bisschen was von der tonkabohne mit rein
[Musik]
das habe ich den mürbeteig und da ist im
prinzip nur wichtig dass man den nicht
lange knetet dass er eben auch schön
kalt bleibt und den denke ich jetzt ab
da kommt hier eine chance schön flach so
könnte nämlich schneller ab und dann
kann ich irgendwo etwa eine halbe stunde
in den kühlschrank stellen jetzt ist der
teig gut durchgeführt und ich nehme
jetzt heraus dass rolle ich ihnen hier
ein bisschen flach aus es stützt sich
den einfach direkt auf meine back folie
kann meinem tortenring nehmen den habe
ich bereits auf 24 cm eingestellt
ausstechen den restlichen teig nehme ich
jetzt hier weg konforme ihnen jeweils zu
seiner langen wurst
[Musik]
und dann könnte denen einfach hier an
den rand legen und am rand hochdrücken
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt gut aus und jetzt stelle
ich den so kurz in den kühlschrank und
kann schon mal die käsekuchen
vorbereiten für die käsekuchen wasser
verwende ich 50 gramm weiche butter 85
gramm zucker zweier 250 gramm magerquark
125 milliliter sahne einen teelöffel
übernimmt extrakt und 20 gramm stärke
nämlich die weiche butter und die wir
jetzt hier in der schüssel mit dem
zucker cremig verrührt
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt noch die eier dazu
immer einen nach dem anderen
[Musik]
ich kann ich hier noch den charakter zu
geben dann die sahne bisschen wandel
extrakt und die stärke und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr hier zum beispiel auch
noch ein bisschen orangenschalen abrieb
dazu geben oder zitronen abrieb aber der
kuchen an sich wird ja schon richtig
schön wird sich und aromatisch einfach
kurz warum
[Musik]
kommt ihr käsekuchen machte direkt auf
den teig
dann könnten glatt streichen und der
rand ist jetzt extra hochgezogen denn da
kommt ja später noch die pflaumen
verloren und die sahne creme ab in den
ohren
[Musik]
der kies buchen ist jetzt gebacken und
ich habe ihn noch lauwarm abkühlen
lassen den stelle ich jetzt zur seite
und machte jetzt die frucht schicht für
die frucht schicht verwende ich 75 gramm
zucker 150 milliliter traubensaft 600
gramm zwetschgen die waren aus dem
tiefkühlfach eine unbehandelte orange
ich habe ich noch die gewürze ich habe
zwei sternanis und viertel teelöffel
muscat bleu einen teelöffel zimt und
dann noch zum einkochen 100 milliliter
traubensaft und 23 kg zuerst erhielt
sich jetzt hier meine pfanne
da gebe ich den zucker rein und lass ihn
kurz karamellisieren
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal in einem separaten topf hier das ag
mit dem traubensaft vermischen und bei
marga muster im ono beachten es gibt ein
malaga das ist das pflanzliche mittel
und es gibt noch die akademie ist das
gleiche aber von der mengenangabe her
ist es immer ein bisschen anders und ich
nehme malaga weil es einfach mehr
qualität hat und hinten drauf auf der
verpackung da steht auch immer wie viel
gramm für wie viel masse geeignet ist
also da können dann auch immer schauen
und das agatha wird einfach mit dem
traubensaft verrührt dann las ich kurz
aufkochen und zwei minuten mindestens
sprudelnd kochen
[Musik]
das aks fertig ich habe den herd
ausgemacht der zucker ist karamellisiert
hier gebe ich jetzt nichts dazu sie
waren aus dem tiefkühlfach ich aber
vorher kurz am trauen lassen wenn ihr
könnt da natürlich auch dann andere
flüchtlingen auch in bern zum beispiel
über kirchen alle vier berner habt mit
diesem wissen mit anbraten
[Musik]
der zucker verfügt zwar ein bisschen
aber das ist nicht schlimm da kommt der
gleichlauf der saft mit rein und dann
verkauft das wiederum löst sich wieder
schön
[Musik]
das kann ich hier noch den satz zu
gießen dann kommen hier noch die gewürze
mit rein
und etwas orangenschale abbringen
[Musik]
da ist ganz wichtig dass ihr eine orange
nimmt die unbehandelt ist bei uns ist
hier immer im winter orangen verkauf in
oberhausen
die kommen extra aus italien und da
kaufen wir jetzt einfach noch ganz kurz
einkochen lassen und den stern
allerdings den entferne ich natürlich
später bevor die masse auf die torten
kommt
[Musik]
nämlich die ak masse und fühlst jetzt
zur der pflaumen zwetschgen mache sind
so das parlament hat sich jetzt die
bereits aufgelöst weil es eine wabe
masse ist muss ich jetzt hier die
temperatur mit dem a gar nicht am
gleichen also man kann hier einfach
alles kurz verrühren und wenn ihr keine
stückchen haben möchtet dann könnt ihr
jetzt in sternanis entfernen und dann
die frucht füllung einfach noch kurz
pürieren
aber ich mag es hier ein stück ich
deswegen lassen und jetzt lasse ich hier
die masse ganz kurz lauwarm abkühlen
diese sie dann auf den käsekuchen
natürlich ohne sternanis und stelle den
käsekuchen und dann über nacht in den
kühlschrank so kann die masse richtig
schön fest werden
[Musik]
jetzt ist der käsekuchen gut abwickelt
und noch die pflaumen füllung ist
richtig schön fest jetzt kommt auch die
sahne creme drauf zum fertig stellen
verwende ich 300 gramm sahne etwas salat
einen teelöffel wann ihr extrakt der
hobel mandel und bisher stückchen wenn
es nämlich die sahne führt sie in eine
rührschüssel und kann sie mit etwas
vanille extrakt und seiner partei
einschlage
[Musik]
wenn ich aber vorsichtig debug folie
entfernt
[Musik]
kann ich die sahne creme direkt auf die
flammen füllung streichen und die torte
kann man echt auch sofort vorbereiten
wenn ihr wisst ihr habt am sonntag
besucht können dass die samstagabend
show machen in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann am nächsten tag einfach kurz
die sahne auf streichen die deko drauf
machen und dann ist sie fertig
mit doch gar nicht zu glatt streichen
also wirklich richtig schöne wellig ich
habe jetzt bereits auch die mandeln in
einer pfanne angeröstet ohne fett und
habe sie abkühlen lassen und jetzt kann
ich den käsekuchen oder die torte direkt
ja auch eine platte setzen und
vorsichtig den ring entfernen
[Musik]
und hier kann ich jetzt die mandeln
darauf streuen und auch die bcs
zerkleinern
[Musik]
wie kann man einfach mit den händen so
ein bisschen zerdrücken
[Musik]
wie dann verwandeln drauf also einfach
schön die oberfläche bedeckt und ich
wäre ja nicht dieselbe wenn ich auch ein
bisschen glitzer schnee drauf kommen
würde
[Musik]
es macht spaß klingt einfach frau holle
ich spiele auch bis in frau holle
[Musik]
kann man probieren kurator ist schon
bereit
du weißt wenn man nicht was das ist
wieso weiß es nicht ich bin bereit ich
bin so fit ich bin bereit das wetter her
aber ich weiß dass es ein käsekuchen ist
ja das habe ich ja schon gesagt okay
17.000 von variationen und wie man
gespannt
ich habe es gemacht wie aber sieht es
aus wie ein käsekuchen
nein sie nicht ausgesucht hast du schon
mal die erste überraschung des hammer
raus der sieht wirklich hamm aus der sah
ich aus wie ein kind zu sein
ja doch wie so ein schöner schokoriegel
stimmt aber schön oder
ja wenn du das jetzt sonntags auf deiner
kaffeetafel siehst ja jeden tag kuchen
für dich ist nichts besonderes mehr
aber richtig freuen natürlich mit fragen
muss ich jetzt hier auf deinen teller
mal lieber moral war gut
auch ein größeres stück kommt wisst ihr
was schönes wenn jemand gc auf der torte
herbst und dann gegessen wird dann haben
alle so ein glitzer schnurrbart der
schnäppchen aber wenn es ein ertragen
kann
klasse sowie frage gestellte fragen zu
verstehen fragt eigentlich obwohl die
persische oder wassertraining sind es
kaum glauben setzen weil die noch kals
inhalten gerade überlegt hat sich die
pflaumen mit gebacken hast auch nicht
gern du hast im boden gebacken dann
nimmt dann die creme und dann das ganze
geld zurück
also erst den mürbeteig gemacht käse
kuchen gebacken und dann die pflaumen
füllung gekocht und darauf eine nach dem
kühlschrank und danach dann die sahne
schichten ja ich finde du solltest du
auch mal was packen jetzt bisher schon
bank experte ich finds echt cool zugab
lenker war wieder infrage stellen ja und
zwar was ich bin
wenn wir zum beispiel keine blauen mag
also ich mag das blatt jetzt habe ich
das super ich habe mal was anderes war
nämlich kirschen mandarinen egal was der
kelvin macht zb käsekuchen mit
mandarinen italien also wirklich die
coole reform von also falls ihr den
kuchen auch nach machen wollt dann
schaut auf seinen blog de vorbei
da steht alles noch mal ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch jetzt nach einen
richtig schönen rest sonntag und wir
sehen uns wieder das nächste mal lieber
gruß an kinder kevin calvin hollywood ja
und nicht vergessen um 16 uhr berlin
einschalten box einfach zb um 16 uhr
laufen
jetzt kommt die spülmaschine immer dann
bin ich rede immer im müllschlucker
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit
die weihnachtsbäckerei für kinder heute
bin ich nicht auf der suche nach dem
perfekten back ergebnis sondern nach dem
perfekten backtag für die kinder alles
was das kinderherz höher schlagen lässt
schneemänner häuser und rentiere ganz
wenige zutaten und richtig coole werk
auf süßes weihnacht um ca einfach sally
am dritten advent um 16 uhr